[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
tom waddle former bears wide receiver
co-host
of waddle and sylvie on espn 1000 in
chicago and tom joins us now how is
morale in chicago tom
very low it sucks like we were on the
air dan it was think it was four o'clock
central time when the news came
i laughed i mean i think it was full
belly laugh and was one of those kind of
nervous
but uh hey i expected this effing
decision to happen um but yeah we got it
we had two hours of people
hot as the day is long that just they
could i can't understand it myself so i
understood
why why they were upset all right take
me back to
when russell's agent through adam
schefter says
here's the four teams if uh seattle
happens to trade us what was that day
like in
in chicago when you realized you were on
the wish list
well my first my first response was why
like why are we on that list like
whatever risk
uh whatever russ is upset with in
seattle there's not enough around him
they don't protect him well enough
whatever the complaint was it was like
russ that ain't going to get any better
here in chicago have you watched bears
football
lately but no i mean there was an
enormous sugar high for sure
that i don't know if you know this dan
but we're kind of in a quarterback
drought here in chicago
it's lasted several decades but
like when when russell wilson one of the
top five quarterbacks in the league over
the last decade puts you on his wish
list
like this city didn't know how to
respond like like
i'm a realist in a lot of ways um
kind of shaped by my childhood and my
inability to run fast or do anything
athletic so i kind of had
a pretty low expectation level for
things but even i was
kind of intrigued and hopeful thought it
was a long shot but when ross puts us on
his list
i think everyone in this town had
the thought that finally our long
wanted and needed franchise quarterback
was about to be delivered to us
but is there a part of you that wishes
that he didn't put chicago
on that list uh to raise expectations
and then to be
to be cut off at the knees yeah i think
you could make that statement look
like i said my childhood was was was was
really
kind of affected when i think it was
like seven or eight years old i grew up
in cincinnati and all i wanted for
christmas one year was an archie griffin
jersey
i think i got a super tub and super toes
are cool but i wanted an archie griffin
jersey
and honestly from that point forward i
think i kind of just
i've been a person that set the bar at a
very
reasonable level and when russ puts us
on the list it was like going back to
that christmas morning thinking i'm
getting an archie griffin jersey and i
get a super toad like
no offense to andy dalton he's had a
nice career he's been to the postseason
five times he's had
three trips to the super toe but or
super or
pro bowl but that's a super tone so um
look yeah i think you can make the case
that that
it it raised expectation levels to a
lofty spot that really
in a lot of ways you know we probably if
we looked at it a little closer weren't
more reasonable
um i don't know though kind of if i
circle back like every now and again
it's fun to dream
especially where we've been with the
quarterback position so now i'm going to
reverse
my answer and say no i'm glad he put us
on his list
would you rather have mitchell trubisky
or andy dalton
at this point i'd rather have andy
dalton and look
my rationale is that the coach lost
complete
confidence in the quarterback a while
ago i don't even know if matt ever had
confidence in mitch
mitch was drafted in 2017 and we're not
going to
re-litigate what ryan pace did wrong
there it's quite obvious
um but i thought that that that matt
never showed that he truly trusted mitch
i don't think he felt mitch fit his
system and i think that was on full
display especially at the end of last
year nick foles gets hurt
mitch comes back they totally tailor the
offense to
to mitch's strengths um they kind of
scaled things back to cut the field in
half and
it's what matt should have done i mean i
think matt deserves some of the
criticism from mitch's lack of
consistent performance but
ultimately he's a professional
quarterback and quite frankly i just
don't think he was
he was good enough but the moral of the
story really for me is
is that if you watch how plays were
called against the saints in the
postseason and the green bay packers in
the final game of the season
like we could sit around and talk about
how that offense was clicking and
scoring 40
against the bad texans defense or a bad
jags defense
but the truth is is when you step up in
class and you've modified your offense
and you don't trust your quarterback to
do anything you're not going to beat the
better team so
like matt lost faith in mitch and once
that happens you've got to move on and i
think the rams are the best example of
that
sean mcveigh lost faith and and jared
goff as their quarterback and what did
sean mcvay do he decided
look we appreciate your participation
and the effort all that you did for us
but this isn't going to work and he
traded for matthew stafford so
that to me is kind of the best example
that that kind of defines my point for
this so
i you know mitch will be in the league
for a decade great kid hard worker
teammates like him
struggles in my mind to play the
position from the pocket and
like i just think matt couldn't coexist
with him any longer not because he
didn't like him as a kid but he didn't
trust it
are the bears out of the quarterback
market
i think what what i was told by this
this signing basically was is they
they swung and missed with russ they
tried to complete the hail mary it was
incomplete
um i think they're gonna try to move up
in the first round and grab one of these
guys they were north dakota looking at
trey lance i think they'll try to find a
way to get one of these quarterbacks
um and then kind of reset the clock for
both ryan pace
and matt running this program here in
chicago um
look i i i think ryan pace is is you
know it's in his dna
to to to think big so does it mean he's
still not going to try to make a trade
for someone probably not
but at this point like i was an advocate
if you can't get russ and you can't get
watson and watson really was never an
option and russ i thought was a long
shot
my advice to them had they called me
which they don't would have been to just
do nothing you've got andy dalton on
your roster it's nick foles like it's a
bridge to nowhere it's a bridge to
mediocrity it's a bridge to eight and
eight
so why not save the ten million dollars
and and try to fill some holes in other
areas and try to fix your team in
different ways keep
keep your powder dry and keep your draft
picks
that's what i would have advised them to
do so i thought it was really an
unnecessary decision to sign andy
but i wouldn't rule out ryan still going
to the plate and trying to swing and hit
the ball
out keep your head up okay i can't
why not i'm i mean listen
this is living in this town this team's
in my blood like you've got your jersey
it's got your face on it i got a jersey
that steals despite what they've done at
the quarterback position mine says
chicago bears
they're in my heart they're in my blood
dan when when you can't get the
quarterback
position right over the course of 90
years it stings
could you ever see jim harbaugh coaching
the bears if there was a coaching change
i like that's a really tough question
for me to answer to be honest with you
because i have such a great
feeling in my body for jim and who he
was
like there aren't many guys in the
league back in the early 90s late 80s
that would have trusted
me and thrown the ball to me and jim did
um and he was such a great competitor on
the field
and i loved him as in the way he
approached the game
um with that said
like his nfl resume is great if you go
back and look what he did in san
francisco but like what has struck what
have they struggled with in michigan
to find the quarterback what i mean like
what are we doing here in chicago
we're trying to find a quarterback like
forget i brought it up john
forget i brought it up forget it yeah i
mean like it's my bad
makes me feel bad like i mean keep
kicking me dude my bad
my bad hey spring training white sox
going to be good this year
yeah and actually they're on our on our
station the espn 1000 it's it's going to
be a lot of fun yeah so
i got that to look forward to yeah i'd
start drinking early on st
paddy's day oh damn it's it's a day that
ends in a y
i'm gonna have one as soon as we're done
thank you bud good to talk to you tell
sylvie we said hello
i will thanks dan that's tom waddle